let's talk about the foxnews presidency
the donald trump presidency
can in a sense be called the foxnews
presidency because we know that donald
trump mostly watches fox news we know
that donald trump will often tweet in
relation to or get involved in topics
that come up during fox news programs
including fox and friends their morning
show which seems to be a favorite of
donald trump's and it's happened many
times that a topic trump hasn't talked
about before will be discussed on fox
and friends in the morning and then
suddenly five minutes later ten minutes
later Donald Trump is tweeting about it
and he's getting involved in it
we then subsequently learned that
there's actually more to it because not
only is Donald Trump's sort of agenda
being set in a sense by Fox and Friends
in the morning Donald Trump we learned
is regularly speaking privately to Fox
News propagandist Sean Hannity they'll
often speak at night Hannity sort of
putting Trump to bed as the case may be
in practice and Sean Hannity all of a
sudden has significant influence on the
president and on this sort of
agenda-setting power that is given to a
lot of the people that Donald Trump
chooses to allow into his inner circle
it's getting even worse though there is
now a Daily Beast article which reveals
that Fox News host Tucker Carlson who of
course has lost many advertisers over
his xenophobic rants on the channel in
the last year or so Tucker Carlson is
privately advising Donald Trump on
topics of foreign policy
it appears specifically related to the
Middle East and most recently it
specifically related to Iran what on
earth this Tucker Carlson know about
Iran you might ask and that's a good
question although it appears that Tucker
Carlson may actually be advising Donald
Trump in the right direction when it
comes to the topic of Iran and I'll get
to that in a second
you'll maybe to set the stage
remember that Donald Trump's Iran policy
has been completely abortive abortive
rather so if he's been influenced by
Tucker Carlson already it's possible
that Tucker Carlson has been guiding him
astray and in general when I hear that
Trump is taking foreign policy at
from the guy who lost advertisers for
lamenting that the United States as it
becomes less white is less American I'm
concerned but and this is a big but in
this particular case reports are that
Tucker Carlson has been telling Donald
Trump not to take military action
against Iran which seems to be the exact
opposite of what people around Donald
Trump like Warhawk National Security
Advisor John Bolton would be telling
Donald Trump to do there's a serious
senior administration official who told
The Daily Beast that Tucker Carlson has
been bashing Donald Trump's more hawkish
administration members and in fact on
Monday Tucker Carlson actually said on
his Fox news program that the
intelligence around Iran and the recent
oil tanker attack in the Gulf of Oman is
reminding him of the bogus intelligence
that led up to the war in Iraq back in
2003 and this is not surprising I mean
Tucker Carlson has talked about this
before this clip I'm going to play for
you is from almost a year ago and you
will hear Tucker Carlson saying that a
war with Iran would destroy Donald
Trump's presidency he's been saying this
for a while we are moving toward however
slowly some kind of confrontation with
Iran and that should worry everybody but
it should especially be of concern to
anyone who supported the president if
President Trump decides to go to war
with Iran it will destroy his presidency
just as the Iraq war destroyed the
presidency of his Republican predecessor
George W Bush attacking Iran is not like
intervening in Libya or Syria or even
like invading Iraq it entails far
greater risk and much higher costs where
Tucker is wrong is that while in an
academic and historical sense the Iraq
war did destroy george w bush's
presidency he still got reelected while
that Iraq war was going on and the
talking point of we shouldn't change
horses midstream was one of the
arguments that realistically got George
W Bush some more votes so while it's
true that war with Iraq destroyed Bush's
legacy electorally
it wasn't bad for him and electorally
donald trump going to war with iran
might also not be a bad thing for him
but ultimately tucker carlson is right
here and i have
no problem saying I mean listen if
Tucker Carlson is pushing Donald Trump
to stay out of Iran that's good it's
disgusting that xenophobe tucker carlson
has influence in this way and that he
seems to have been brought in to donald
trump's very vile and disgusting inner
circle which includes people like sean
hannity in addition now to Tucker
Carlson Carlson is regularly wrong about
endless things
it's pathetically embarrassing that
Donald Trump is so influenced by what
goes on at Fox News day in and day out
and the agenda-setting power that Fox
News and its hosts have gotten is
disturbing to anyone who is clear
thinking and rational but but I don't
want Donald Trump going into Iran and if
Tucker Carlson is telling Donald Trump
not to go into Iran that's a good thing
there's just lots of other people who
know much more and are otherwise much
more correct on world issues than Tucker
Carlson who would also be telling Donald
Trump
you shouldn't go into Iran and by the
way Donald Trump is now insisting that
Iran abide by the Iran nuclear deal
which he bailed out of months ago and we
are going to talk about that a little
bit later on in the program make sure
you were following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show is our
handle on Instagram and while you're
there follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman I just surpassed I believe it's
fifty thousand followers on Instagram
and I would love for you to make at 50
thousand and one follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman quick break much much
more coming up after this today's
program brought to you in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a great
service that i use all the time what
they do is they take thousands of the
most popular non-fiction books including
the newest bestsellers they condense
them into 15-minute audiobooks that you
can listen to and you still get the most
crucial information and insights from
each book and I've listened to a ton of
books on blink as'
I recently checked out sock
naah mcc's by Simon Cooper we do have
after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink Escom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you'd like
it you can continue enjoying thousands
of condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa k ma n